how do you respond when a screenwriter
tells you a screenplay does not need
structure I
disagree
um most of the screenplays that I've
read or that I've had a chance to
develop or work on over the years have a
structure so most of the professional
writers have I come across a screenplay
that doesn't adhere to structure no I
don't remember reading one um at least
one that doesn't adhere to at least two
or three of the big beats um where you
do need some kind of push into the story
you know of a threea structure
television doesn't work like that you
know episodes have 5x structures or 7x
structures but if you lay a if you lay a
certain structure over a season you can
see where the elevations and the Rises
and Falls go um and to me that's
structure um I've never been told by a
writer that you don't need structure I I
will say that sorry you don't need
structure I've read it you know and I've
read people who don't necessarily adhere
structure or people who can sit down and
and write a screenplay without an
outline you know if they've been doing
it long enough they probably can uh and
I'm not someone who's going to say no
don't do that because people do have
their own process on how they create um
at the heart of it it is a creative art
form storytelling and people will tell
it the way they want to tell it it just
happens to be my thing and um I've seen
it work too many times in both in the
studio you know and in movies that I
didn't have anything to do with for it
for it not to be relevant how can you
tell whether a screenwriter understands
the craft of screenwriting I guess it's
all the elements really you know in the
first 10 to 15 pages of reading a
screenplay I'll know if they understand
structure I'll know if they understand
the importance of setting and how it
impacts a character's Journey or a
relationship um I'll know you know if
they understand formatting and that's a
big thing you know if if your first two
or three three pages has a whole bunch
of spelling mistakes I just I can't you
know it's too distracting which means
you haven't taken the time to really
look over your screenplay um and so I
can usually tell from the world build
building the formatting uh whether
there's an inciting incident which is
why if I have 15 to 20 screenplays to
read on a weekend I'm not going to read
all of them you know um I might get to
page 20 or just the First Act and go
okay this is good I can see where this
might go then I'll send it up to the
next level um or I'll read the first 10
to 15 and go this person has no idea how
to write dialogue the description is all
over the place um again if it's coming
in from a known writer I'm not going to
tell ariasa how to write a screenplay
I'm just not you know it's quite obvious
you know and he doesn't adhere to
certain structures um but he does he
does adhere to a 3A structure structure
in in my opinion you can lay a 3X
structure over hereditary and it works
um but you know is there a rule where it
has to be four lines of description
before you move on it's unspoken but if
he's going to write 10 lines it's
probably for a reason and he's allowed
to because he's directing his own work
you know if you're taking in his
screenplay you're taking in him as a
director as well so um that's a
different scenario uh for a writer who's
just submitting a script you want a
crisp clean read and that's why you're
economical with the way you you write a
screenplay which is why you adhere to
some rules and adhere to structure and
you try to be you you you put some
effort into rewriting a screenplay but
usually in 10 to 15 if they haven't
identified a main point of view you know
if their main character suddenly appears
on Main on page 15 or 20 probably I
don't know now there are movies like
filmer and Louise for instance who which
I love um which you could look at and
say well there's two main characters
right there's two main points of view
there's ther and Louise so whose story
is it then is it one person's one
character's story instead of
another if you look at the structure of
the First Act which goes longer than
normal because you are establishing two
stories it's Louisa's story she's
driving the action she's the one getting
them out of there she's running from her
life and she's dragging thma with her
and thma is dramatic change over the
course of that movie and Louise's as
well is just palpable in the way that
they do that but and they are really two
main characters but whose story is it
you know I want to see in that first 15
pages whose story it is if I can't I
then usually for me that's how I can
tell a writer is probably not as
experienced what are several things that
screenwriters forget let's say one of
them being that screenwriting is a
visual medium that's definitely one um
and it's something I encounter in
workshops all the time is that they'll
get into the dialogue or they'll get
into you know trying to get their story
out so quickly that it all becomes ex
you know Exposition not realizing that
we need to discover a character and
their change and the revelations in
their story over the course of the movie
not in the First Act they often forget
that when we first meet a character at
the beginning of the screenplay they
they've had a life before this so there
is that what we call the ghost before
the screenplay what were they before the
screenplay you know what happened before
the screenplay starts and that CU they
were you're going to have to bring that
with you um they forget that transitions
are important between scenes you know
what does that mean being able to
transition visually from a roulette
wheel into the next scene and a car's
wheel spinning you know think of things
visually um again you know we went over
this too but the idea of when a
character enters a scene they're coming
from somewhere else where were they what
happened what's the attitude they're
bringing in and a lot of this is you
know one of the good things that I
experienced at AFI um but even before
that is I was an actor and so I did
actor training one of the best things a
screenwriter can do is do an actor
course do an acting course learn about
motivation learn about what it is to
create a character physically um and I
think that you know that's area where
sometimes writers aren't strong is that
they they don't understand the physical
aspect of creating what's on the page um
not everyone but I think uh some of the
common mistakes is just you know a
screenplay is not a piece of literature
it's just not it has a completely
different format in general um and it's
there to create a blueprint and an
inspiration for
collaboration from other departments you
know film isn't created by a
screenwriter um but if you have a strong
blueprint that's succinct and clear and
has those clear structure for me um then
you're going to attract attention from
other departments who are going to go
this is a great screenplay I want to
direct that
um uh which is what happened with
collateral with Tom Cruz and Jamie Fox
you know that was meant to be an
independent film and then it crossed I
think it crossed Tom Cruz's agent desk
at the right time and he read it went
wow this is a good screen play next
minute Tom Cruz is gone then let's do
that because the foundation of the movie
The Script was really strong um so I
think we you know as writers you forget
that sometimes that you're not writing
in isolation you're writing to attract
other artists to your work I think
another thing you've said is that
screenwriter should not tell an actor
what to do in the screenplay or even a
director how to direct the scene we talk
about that yes
um I see it a lot and I think this is
very subjective sometimes for me I don't
want to see a script that has you know
camera angles to or you know uh closeup
on or any of that kind of camera
movement in the initial first draft that
we end up sending out to be read it
should be the story there's a way of
attracting the eye visually through
description rather than having to put a
camera angle in there um and as far as
the telling an actor to move I I'm
always seeing parentheticals in a script
used the wrong way you know um scratches
their head you know if they're confused
or or telling an actor how to play
something I think there are exceptions
if you should be aiming towards telling
an actor how to feel about something you
know if you have to use that in the
description where you know it might be a
little bit unclear how they're supposed
to feel in that moment then you can use
a piece of description to do that
telling them how to move um generally is
not going to be accepted that well u in
fact if you look at some of the scenes
of whiplash right in the dialogue and
description and then watch what's
happening on screen with JK
Simmons he's he's not even going to read
that he's going to play it the way that
it's meant to be felt and that's the way
an actor generally will come at
something so parentheticals should be
used to make a line clear you know if I
say I don't know right there are a
million ways to say that so let's
clarify that for an actor by putting
sarcastic in there or flippant give them
an attitude not a way to move and I
think that uh that's a common mistake I
see in screenplays too is telling an
actor how they should move rather than
how they should feel or Play a
scene interesting so even if someone
wants to add sort of layers of the
experience or or add to the
character there there's other ways to
convey it that that that's being too
you're controlling it you're being too
uh sort of precious with the work yes in
a way I mean when you look at the
different processes that are going to be
attracted to a screenplay a director is
going to look at something and tear
apart anyway and they're going to block
the scene and they're going to create
the scene and the camera angles with the
DP in a way to convey the essence of the
scene which isn't necessarily built into
how an actor moves so I think that the
best way to create something like that
is to focus on the central crisis and
the emotional aspects of the film inside
the dialogue inside the action inside
what's happening but not necessarily
tell an actor how to move unless it's
specific to how you want them to feel
about something you know or contrasting
you know if someone's smiling at another
character and it looks like they're
going to hit them but they pat them
instead you know playing with that idea
um you can still do that by not telling
an actor how to move move if there's too
much of that you'll find it it'll get
cut anyway because what you want to get
to is the meat of what's really going on
in the scene and it's not generally the
physical the physical is a
representation of the emotional that's
that's being portrayed in the scene and
sometimes actors will play that
differently